[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى هذه الصور نتابعها مباشره من موسكو
التي تعرضت لهجوم بمسيارات هو الثاني من
نوعه خلال شهر ما تسبب باضرار وصفت بانها
الطفيفه لعده مباني واصابه شخصين
الى طهان الان
والتي اعلنت اليوم عن تفاهم مع وكاله
الطاقه الذريه في شان موقع يشتبه في
احتوائه جزيئات اليورانيوم وسط حديثا عن
تواصل مع الاوروبيين ورسائل ما واشنطن
بشان الملف النووي
ولان الى بلغراد وازمه تتفاقم مع برشتينا
عاصمه كوسوفو بعد ان قطع الصرب الانتخابات
البلديه التي نظمتها حكومه كوسوفو في
ابريل لانهاء الفراغ المؤسسي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
حرب اوكرانيا تصل الى موسكو مع تبادل
استهداف عاصمتي البلدين بوتين يقول ان هدف
الضربات الاوكرانيه هو استدراج روسيا كيف
تقول انها ليست مرتبطه بشكل مباشر بالهجوم
على موسكو واشنطن تؤكد انها لا تؤيد
تنفيذها هجمات داخل روسيا
وسياسيا مصادر اوروبيه تتحدث عن مساء لعقد
قمه دوليه بشان الصراع لا تحضرها روسيا
وتيره الاستيطان الاسرائيلي تتصاعد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه غرب نابلس بؤره
عشوائيه جديده يتم انشاؤها على اراضي بلده
دراستيا وشرقها اعاده فتح مدرسه دينيه في
بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه وفي تقرير سري
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو الدول الاعضاء
لتبني مواقف لا لبس فيها ضد تغيير وضع
القدس
هدنه جديده ومعارك متواصله في السودان
اشتباكات بمختلف انواع الاسلحه في جنوب
الخرطوم واطلاق نار كثيف جنوب شرقي مدينه
الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان وفي ظهور
النادر البرهان يتوعد قوات الدعم السريع
باستخدام القوه المميته ان لم تنفع لما
وصفه بصوت العقل
حراك في ملف ايران النووي على الصعيدين
التقني والسياسي
جديد مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه في شان موقع
يشتبه في احتوائه جزيئات من اليورانيوم
المخصب وزير الخارجيه الايراني يؤكد تبادل
رسائل ووثائق غير رسميه مع واشنطن في شان
المفاوضات النوويه عبر وسط اقليميين
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه وقفنا عند المشهد في اليوم الاول
بعد تمديد اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان لخمسه ايام فكيف بدت الصوره سماع
اطلاق نار كثيف جنوب شرقي مدينه الابيض في
ولايه شمال كردفان واشتباكات عنيفه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع استخدمت فيها
المدفعيه الثقيله في منطقه الكادرو شماليه
الخرطوم وكذلك اطلاق نار متقطع جنوبي
الخرطوم وفي الخرطوم بحري كذلك لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هي فرصه صمود وقت اطلاق
النار الجديد
10% قالوا ان الفرص كبيره
30% راوا ان الفرص محدوده اما ستون في
المئه اعتبروا الف فرص اطلاقا للصمود وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الذي
يظهر الان على الشاشه
ولقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وسط التصاعد التوتر بين بلغراد وبرشتينا
النيتو يرسل قوات اضافيه الى كوسوفو ويحذر
من تداعيات العنف
[موسيقى]
للمره الثانيه منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا
تتعرض العاصمه الروسيه لهجوم بطائرات
مسيره هجوم وصفه النائب الروسي مكسيم
ايفانوس بالاخطر على موسكو منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه قائلا انه لا يوجد روسي
يمكنه الان تجنب الواقع الجديد في
التفاصيل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
الهجوم الاوكرانيه الذي وصفته بالارهابي
تم بثمان طائرات مسيره وانه تم اسقاط خمس
طائرات منها
بمنظومه بانتسير وثلاثه اخرى باستخدام
معدات الحرب الالكترونيه
اما عمده موسكو فقلم جانبه ان الهجوم اسفر
عن اصابه شخصين بجروح طفيفه
[موسيقى]
طائرات مسيره عنوان المرحله في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا العاصمه الروسيه للمره
الثانيه منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا عرضه
لهجوم بطائره مسيره
وصفتهابي متهمه بالوقوف وراءه هي تمني
طائره مسيره وفق وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اسقطت خمس منها في مقاطعه موسكو بمنظومه
بانتير وتلات اخرى باستخدام معدات الحرب
الالكترونيه بينما تعرضت مباني سكنيه في
اطراف موسكو لاضرار طفيفه
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه اشار الى
نحو 32 مسيره شاركت في الهجوم على موسكو
اما موقع ريبال العسكريه الروسي فقال ان
مسيرات 22 الاوكرانيه وهي قادره على
التحليق لنحو 800 كيلومتر رصدت سابقا في
مناطق قريبه من موسكو استهداف موسكو
بالمسيرات يعقب بساعات هجوما روسيا واسعا
بطائره مسيره على العاصمه كياف هو الثالث
في ساعه ولكن ايضا بعشره صواريخ من نوع
اسكندر الباليستيه بعيده البدى واسقطت وفق
روايه الاوكرانيه الرئيس الروسي قال انما
سماه هجوم المسيرات الاوكراني على موسكو
جاء ردا على ضربه روسيه استهدفت قياده
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه وفي حين
تقول كيف انها غير مسؤوله عن اي هجمات
داخل روسيا بدل لافتا نفيو مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه اي علاقه مباشره بالهجوم
الاخير دخان التصعدي بدا جليا في الاشهر
الاخيره الهجوم هو الثاني خلال هذا الشهر
على موسكو حيث استهدفت بدايه الشهر
مسيرتان مقر كريميلين دون اصابات ومنذ ذلك
الحين اخذت الهجمه في العمق الروسي وتيره
متصاعده رغم النفي الاوكراني المتكرر
لمسؤوليتها على الجبهه الشرقيه القصف
المدفعي الاوكراني ينال مقاطعه بالبرود
الروسيه بشكل شبهي وقبل نحو اسبوع في هجوم
غير مسبوق مجموعه عسكريه وصفتهم موسكو
بالقوميين الاوكرانيين في المقاطعه
باستخدام معدات عسكريه غربيه السنه اعقب
ذلك تعرض السفينه الحربيه الروسيه لمقاله
موسكو انه هجوم فاشل من قبل ثلاثه زوارق
مسيره اوكرانيه في البحر الاسود عند
اقتراب السفينه بالمضيق البوسفور وبعد ذلك
بيوم اتهم جهاز امن الدوله الروسي من
وصفهم بالمخاربين الاوكرانيين بمحاوله
التخريب محطتين نوويتين في
البلاد واستهدفه هجوم بمسيرتين ملاغمتين
محطه لتكرير النفط في منطقه
ضخم الذي ينقل النفط الخام من سيبيريا الى
اوروبا على بعد نحو 600 كم من الحدود مع
اوكرانيا مؤشرات متعدده تشيب تحول في مسار
الحرب بعد ان تردد كثيرا حديث عن هجوم
اوكراني مضاد وهو ما يطرح تساؤلات بشان
حجم وطبيعه رد الفعل الروسي وتعامل الغرب
مع هذه التطورات
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن قال ان هجمات
المسيرات الاوكرانيه على موسكو جاءت ردا
على ضربه روسيه استهدفت مركز قياده
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه ووصفه
بمحاوله استدراج لبلاده
سبق وتحدثنا عن امكانيه توجيه ضربات
لمراكيز صنع القرار ومن المنطقي ان هذه
الفئه تضم مركز الاستخبارات العسكريه
والذي وجهت اليه ضربه منذ يومين او ثلاثه
ردا على ذلك اختار النظام كيف طريقا
مختلفا يتمثل في محاولات اثاره الرعب في
روسيا وبين افراد شعبنا بهجومه على
المباني السكنيه هذا بالطبع عمل ارهابي
غير ان منظومات الدفاع الجوي في موسكو
تعاملت معه بشكل مقبول ويوجد ما علينا
العمل عليه
من جهه قلا البيت الابيض في بيان الولايات
المتحده لا تؤيد الهجمات داخل روسيا وانها
ما زالت تجمع المعلومات بشان ما حدث في
موسكو واضاف البيان نواشي تركز على مساعده
اوكرانيا في استعاده سيادتها على اراضيها
وفي تصريح لافت حذر كارير ريكا رئيس
الاركان العامه
حذر من احتمالات حدوث صدام بين روسيا
والنيتو وقال ريكو ان هذا السيناريو
الاسوا يبدو ممكنا وان روسيا تسير على
طريق قد يؤدي لنشوب مثل هذا الصراع وفي
كلمه القاها امام البرلمان التشيكي قال
رئيس الاركان انه على جيوش النيتو تولي
مهمه اساسيه هي الاستعداد لاحتمال صراع
مباشر مع موسكو
ومن كيف معنا الان رومان كوستينكو سكرتير
لجنه الامن القومي ودفاع والاستخبارات في
البرلمان الاوكراني ومن موسكو معنى باسيلي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وضابط
الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي اهلا بكما ابدا
معك سيد رومان كاستانكو
يعني اذا تاملنا ردود الفعل على هجمات
اليوم على موسقف في الواقع هناك وضوح في
الموقف الروسي بوتن يقول هذا الهجوم هو
الرد على استهداف كييف بينما الرد
الاوكراني فيه شيء من الغموض بودياك
مستشار الرئاس الرئيس الاوكراني
ينفي ان تكون ثياب على علاقه مباشره مع
هذه الضربات
كيف نفسر هذا التصريح وهذا الغموض
تعلمون ان لدينا موقف انه اذا لم يكن هناك
موقف معلن رسمي على اي مساله اذا نحن
نلتزم بالصمت ولكننا نفهم جيدا ما يحدث
ومن يقوم بهذه الضربات على روسيا كرد على
الهجمات الارهابيه الروسيه على اراضينا
نحن نرى يوميا الضربات بالمسيرات
والصواريخ لذلك بالطبع الرد سيكون
وقدراتنا الدفاعيه تتطور
وسوف نرد القوات الروسيه للاراضي الروسيه
هل نحن بصدد تكتيك جديد يعني الان يبدو
وكان المعركه تنقل الى العمق الروسي ولا
تكتفي بما يجري على الاراضي الاوكرانيه هل
هذا هو الهجوم المضاد الذي لطالما سمعنا
عنه ام هو تكتيك جديد
لن اقول ان هذا تكتيكا جديدا ولكن هذا رد
اغلب العمليات العسكريه ستكون على اراضينا
بهدف التحرير خاصه حيث الاحتلال المؤقت
ولكن هذه ضربات سوف تساعدنا على تدمير
الاعمال اللوجستيه والخطوط الخلفيه لقوات
العدو ما يسمح
للعدو ان
يدعم قوته في الجبهات ونريد اعاقه هذا
الضربات ستكون على كل الخطوط ولكن الدفاع
سيكون عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله وفي
بعض المناطق
هناك مجموعات متطوعه روسيه تقوم الان
بمحاربه القوات الروسيه
بجانب الطرف الاوكراني
الى اين تتوقعون ان تسير الامور خصوصا ان
استمرار هذه الضربات تحرج موسكو
درجه الاستفزاز يمكن ان تدفعها الى القيام
برد مختلف ما الذي تتوقعونه على المدى
القصير والمدى البعيد
ان روسيا لا تخجل مما تقوم به
لانهم ما قاموا به منذ بدايه الاجتياح
قاموا باعلان انهم سوف يسيطروا على
اوكرانيا بثلاث ايام ثم تم صدهم من كيف
ومن الان الهجمات والضربات تنجح على
اراضيهم ولا يستطيعوا ان يصدوها وقالوا
مسبقا انهم الجيش الثاني على مين ولكن حتى
انظمتهم الدفاعيه الجويه لا تنجح بصد هذه
الهجمات هم لا يخجلوا من شيء ولكني اعتقد
ان في المستقبل ستكون هذه الهجمات اقوى
وادق واكثر وسوف نقوم بكل شيء حتى ننتصر
باسرع وقت ممكن وبعد ذلك سنقوم بهجمه على
مختلف المنشات اشكرك روما
والان ننتقل الى باسيلي فاتيكاروف سيد
فاتيكاروف
عندما يقول النائب الروسي مكسيما ايفانوف
ان هجوم اليوم هو الاخطر منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وان على
كل شخص في روسيا الان ان يدرك انه لا يمكن
ان يتجنب الواقع الجديد ما المقصود
بالواقع الجديد هنا
هذه ليست اخطر هجمه كما قيل للاسف روسيا
في هذا القرن تعرضت للارهاب مسبقا ونعلم
التفجيرات التي كانت تحدث في المترو وفي
مختلف المنشات اليوم هذه الهجمه فشلت من
ثماني مسيرات خمسه
اسقطوا بالانظمه
الروسيه بانسر اس
وثلاثه منهم انزلوا باجهزه الدفاع
الالكترونيه كان لدينا تضرر بسيط في بعض
المنازل ولكن هذا لا شيء لم يجرح احد جرح
شخصين جروح بسيطه لدينا انظمه دفاع جويه
قويه
وموسكو يدافع عنها بقوه والارهابيين لن
ينجحوا سوف نقاومهم في المستقبل ربما
الجرح المادي كما تصفه بسيط ولكن الجرح
المعنوي هو الذي ربما محل تساؤل هنا
والسؤال الى اي درجه سيدفع موسكو الى
تغيير استراتيجياتها
وما نوع التحديات في الواقع التي تراها
موسكو في هذه المرحله تحديدا
اعتقد ان احد اهداف هذه العمليات
الارهابيه على موسكو كان
تشكيك المجتمع او بث الشعور انهم وقعوا في
فخ او اجبارهم على الحزن
كلا هذا ارهاب ولن نغير
التكتيكات والاهداف التي وضعت من السيد
الرئيس
بوتين هذه الاهداف واضحه نزعم نظام النادي
والقضاء عليه ونزع سلاحه وسوف نستمر في
هذا المعركه الاساسيه الان اصبحت على
الاراضي
الروسيه وتعلمين ان حسب الدستور لوغانك
ودانيسكو وداباروجي وخرسون هذه ايضا مواقع
روسيه اشكرك بس
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وضبط
الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي شكرا
نقلا عن مستشاري الرئيس الاوكراني او
مستشار رئاسيا اوكرانيا رفيع ودبلوماسيين
اوروبيين ان اوكرانيا وحلفائها يخططون
لعقد قمه لزعماء العالم من شانها استبعاد
روسيا بهدف حشد الدعم لشروط كييف لانهاء
الحرب ووفق الصحيفه فان خطه القمه تحظى
بدعم قوي من القاده الاوروبيين وان فرنسا
والدنمارك والسويد عرضت استضافته عفوا
عرضت استضافتها كما ان القاده الاوروبيين
بمن فيهم الرئيس الفرنسي يضغطون من اجل
مشاركه الدول التي انحازت الى روسيا او
رفضت اتخاذ موقف بشان الحرب ونقلت عن
دبلوماسيين اوروبيين
طلب في وقت مبكر من هذا العام من الرئيس
الفرنسي مساعدته في التواصل الدولي مع
قاده مثل الرئيس الصيني
وبحسب الصحيفه فان هناك مساعيه مع كييف
لاعاده صياغه خطه السلام الاوكرانيه من
عشر نقاط
بطرق تجعلها اكثر قبولا للقوى العالميه
الاخرى مثل الهند والبرازيل والسعوديه
والصين
وفي فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على حرب
المسيرات بين روسيا واوكرانيا ونسال ضيف
الحصاد عن اهميه هذا السلاح على جبهات
القتال
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها تنظر
بخطوره بالغه لاقدام عناصر ستيطانيه مسلحه
على نصب خيام تمهيدا لاقامه بؤره
استيطانيه جديده على اراضي بلده دراستيا
في قضاء محافظه نابلس واعتبرت الوزاره في
بيان ان الخطوه هي ترجمه رسميه لسياسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تسابق الزمن
لتنفيذ اكبر عدد من المشاريع الاستيطانيه
بهدف حسم مستقبل الضفه الغربيه لصالح
الاحتلال وفق تعبير البيان واضاف البيان
ان هذه السياسه تسعى لاطلاق يد المستوطنين
على طريق ربط جميع المستوطنات ببعضها
وتحويلها لتجمع استيطاني واحد يرتبط
بالعمق الاسرائيلي
هذا هو حذر تقرير سري للاتحاد الاوروبي
مما وصفه بالتسارع الكبير للضغط
الاسرائيلي على القدس ومحاوله تغيير
الواقع الديموغرافي فيها واشارت تقرير
الذي حصلت صحيفه
على نسخه منه انه يتعين على بروكسل ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تعارض بشكل لا لبس
فيه الخطط احاديه الجانب التي تهدف لتغيير
وضع وحدود القدس واضاف التقرير ان اسرائيل
سرعت الى حد كبير في العام الاخير الضغط
على المواطنين الفلسطينيين فيها
وفي سياق التوسع الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي
كذلك اعد مستوطنون متطرفون انشاء مدرسه
دينيه في بؤره حمش الاستيطانيه شمل غربيه
مدينه نابلس في الضفه الغربيه وذكرت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان هذه الخطوه جاءت
بموافقه من وزيريا دفاع الاسرائيلي
والماليه رغم انتقاد قاده في اجهزه الامن
لتلك الخطوه
انتهاك استيطاني جديد بحق الفلسطينيين هذه
المره في قمه جبل القبيبات فوق اراضي
قريتي برقه وسيله الظهر بين جنين ونابلس
فبعد شهرين على الغاء حكومه الاحتلال
قانون فك الارتباط في شمال الضفه الغربيه
اقتحمت مجموعات استيطانيه متطرفه ليلا
بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه المخلاه منذ عام
2005 واعادت ارساء بيوت المتنقله تمثل
مدرسه دينيه في موقع جديد داخل البؤره
بدعم من وزراء حكومه اليمين المتطرف
وحمايه جيش الاحتلال في محاوله لشرعنه
البؤره
تاريخيه نحن على بعد خطوات معدوده لتصحيح
الظلم الرهيب بترحيل سكان حومش منذ ذلك
الوقت ونحن نعمل ليل نهار لتصحيح الظلم
الشخصي ليس فقط بحق المطرودين وانما بحق
امتي ودوله اسرائيل
بعد تسع سنوات على اخلائهم تحجج متطرفون
بالعوده اليها لاداء طقوس دينيه وهو ما
رافقه تعزيز للوجود العسكري في المنطقه
واستمرار اعتداءات المستوطنين وتعطيل حياه
الاف الفلسطينيين
كل مره بتصير شادي ابو عمر قال انهم
تمكنوا خلال السنوات الاخيره من انتزاع
اربعه قرارات من المحاكم الاسرائيليه لمنع
عوده المستوطنين الى حومش
الحكومه ضربه بعرض الحائط كل القرارات
واللي اخذناها من المحكمه الاسرائيليه
واجت وضعت حجر الاساس لمستوطنه حومش ولكن
هذا يشكل هاجس للشعب الفلسطيني والاهلي
بركه ولا الكره المجاوره سباسطي بالزاريا
والمناطق المجاوره ولكن في ارادتنا وقوتنا
لن تعود حامش
وفي ظل الاجراءات الاستيطانيه الاسرائيليه
احاديه الجانب المرفوضه من قبل المجتمع
الدولي ادانت مؤسسات حقوقيه اسرائيليه
واوساط رسميه فلسطينيه هذه الخطوه هذه
شرعنا لبؤره عشوائيه
تندرج في اطار محاولات دوله الاحتلال
تحويل طابع الصراع من سياسه الى ديني
اسرائيل تستغل ازدواجيه المعايير الدوليه
وتسابق الزمن من اجل تسريع عمليات الضم
التدريجي الزاحف للضفه الغربيه المحتله
اعاده المستوطنين المتطرفين تشييد مدرسه
دينيه في بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه تترجم
مساعي الحكومه اليمنيه للحفاظ على
توليفتها من اجل مصالح المستوطنين لكن هذا
الواقع ينذر بتعزيز فرص العوده الى مشاهد
التوتر والغليان مع تصدي الفلسطينيين في
القرى المجاوره لهذه المشاريع الاستيطانيه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره نابلس فلسطين
ومن رام الله معنا الان الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور غسان في
الحصاد يعني
المشهد يتكرر مرات والاخرى وقبل ان نتحدث
عن الموقف الاوروبي دعني اسالك عن الموقف
الفلسطيني هنا هل يملك شيء هل يملك ورقه
لم يستخدمها حتى الان بهذا الصدد
الحقيقه الشعب الفلسطيني يعني متمسك بارضه
ورافض لهذه الخطوات ومواظب على مقاومتها
بكل الاشكال المتاحه واعتقد ان السبب
الوحيد الذي يعيق نجاح الخطط الاسرائيليه
بالسيطره على مزيد من الاراضي الفلسطينيه
هو ان يعني المواطنين الفلسطينيين وسكان
القرى المجاوره لهذه المستوطنات التي تسعى
للتوسع بدعم من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
يقاومون ذلك يقاومون ذلك بكل الاساليب
الممكنه باجسادهم
باشكال عديده جدا نسمع عنها يوميا في
مواقع في عشرات
لانه في حقيقه الامر جوهر الصراع الان
الدائر بين الشعب الفلسطيني واسرائيل هو
حول السيطره على الارض والحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه لنوعين من الاسباب
تسرع من العمليه الى حد كبير النوع الاول
هو داخلي اسرائيل لانه لدى هذه الحكومه
التزامات اتجاه ناخبيها بان تكون مختلفه
من حيث اسم الصراع لصالح اسرائيل ولذلك هي
اكثر شراسه واكثر سرعه ومجموعه الثانيه من
الاسباب تتعلق بالجانب الاخر
يعني الدعم الدولي
للشعب الفلسطيني هذا الموقف الدولي الذي
كان يعادي الاستيطان بشكل نشيط ويضغط الى
حد ما على اسرائيل للحد من التوسع
الاستيطاني لم يعد بنفس الزخم والتقرير
الذي جمعنا اليه تفضلي هذا التقرير هذا هو
بالضبط ما اردت ان اسالك عنه وانت تتحدث
عن تسارع كبير والتقرير يتحدث عن تحذير من
هذا التسارع وانه ان يتخذ موقف لا لبس فيه
كما جاء في البيان الذي نقلته صحيفه البيس
هل يكفي هذا يعني هل هل هناك حاجه لشيء
اكثر من قوانين توسان كما يحدث مع البي دي
سي مع المقاطعه مع مواضيع اخرى كثيره تتخذ
وتجرم وتحرم الموقف من الجانب الاخر
نعم هناك حاجه لاشياء اكثر بكثير من مثل
هذا البيان هذا البيان يعني جيد ولغته
متقدمه نسبيا ولكنه يقسم على اللغه يقتصر
على
الالتزام اللفظي ولا يتعداه الى اخذ
اجراءات ضاغطه على اسرائيل ثانيا اوروبا
يعني مع احترامنا وتقديرنا لاهميه اوروبا
ودورها الى انه تاثيرها على اسرائيل محدود
الجهه التي تستطيع ان تؤثر على اسرائيل
وتحدث فرق اذا يعني كان لها موقفي
الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده
الحقيقه يعني هناك تراجع كبير في معارضتها
للاستيطان الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اسرائيل لا
ترى ان هناك يعني قوه كبيره اختصار شديد
السبب هذا التراجع
السبب اولا ضعف الموقف الفلسطيني الرسمي
وثانيا ضعف الموقف العربي الرسمي لانه
الدعم العربي الرسمي للموقف الفلسطيني
السياسي والدبلوماسي والدولي كان عاملا
هاما في تعزيز هذا الموقف واخذه بجديه
اكثر من العالم الخارجي
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى السودان الان اذ قال قائد الجيش
السوداني ورئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان ان القوات المسلحه لم تستخدم ما
وصفه بالقوه المميته وانها ستضطر الى ذلك
اذا لم ينصع العدو لصوت العقل بحسب قوله
ورغم تمديد الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تواصلت الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
والابيض
تنتهي هدى وتمدد اخرى دون ان يلوح في
الافق امل في خروج السودان من محنته
الحاليه السعوديه والولايات المتحده رحبت
بقبول طرفي النزاع الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع تمديد الهدنه خمسه ايام يقول
البلدان رعايا الهدنه المنتهيه ومدتها
سبعه ايام ان الطرفين خرقاها مرات عديده
لكنها مكنت رغم ذلك من ايصال المساعدات
لنحو مليوني شخص بعد اعلان تمديد قال مصدر
عسكري بالجيش السوداني ان قوه من الدعم
السريع شنت هجوما على مقر الكتيبه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه وسط الخرطوم ودارت
الشباكات عنيفه شمالي الخرطوم بين الجيش
والدعم السريع استخدمت فيها المدفعيه
الثقيله وشهدت نيالا عاصمه جنوب دارفور
مواجهات بعد اعلان تمديد الهدنه في ظل هذه
الاجواء يعلن قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان خلال تفقده قوات الجيش في
مواقع لم يكشف عنها
القوات المسلحه لم تستخدم ما وسطها بالقوه
المميته وانها ستضطر الى ذلك اذا لم ينصع
العدو لصوت العقل حسب قوله البرهان اضاف
ان الموافقه على تمديد الهدنه كان لتسهيل
انسياب الخدمات للمواطنين لم يحدد البرهان
ماذا يعني بالقوه المميته لكن كلامه يحمل
تهديدا بالانتقال الى مرحله اخرى من
المواجهه مع الدعم السريع ومع استمرار
اعلان الهدن وخرقها وتاثير الاعمال
العسكريه في عمل المؤسسات يزداد الوضع
الانسان سوءا منظمه اطباء حول العالم
اعلنت في بيان خروج تسع مؤسسات طبيه
بولايه الجزيره المتاخمه لولايه الخرطوم
عن الخدمه بسبب احتلالها من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع هذا الوضع دفع بمئات الالاف
الى الهجره والنزوح تقول الامم المتحده ان
نحو 700 الف سوداني هربوا من العاصمه
الخرطوم وحدها اما على مستوى البلد كلي
فقد نزح اكثر من مليون سوداني الى مناطق
امنه هربا من المعارك فيما لجا نحو
30000 اخرين الى دول الجوار ويقول برنامج
الغذاء العالمي ان مليونين ونصف مليون
سوداني سيصبحون مهددين بالمجاعه خلال اشهر
اكد مصدر ايراني مطلع للجزيره توصل الى
تسويه مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بشان احد المواقع التي تشهد تحقيقا بشان
وجود جزيئات اليورانيوم واضاف المصدر
الايراني ان التسويه هي بشان موقع مروان
ووجود جزيئات يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 83
وكذا المصدر ان طهران وافقت في مارس اذار
الماضي على اعاده نصب عدد من كاميرات
المراقبه في احدى منشاتها النوويه ولكن
على الا يتم ارسال معلوماتها للوكاله
الدوليه بل ان يجري تخزينها في شرائح خاصه
ورغم تعليق المحادثات النوويه في فيينا
بين ايران والغرب فان وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبد اللهيان يؤكد ان
طهران مستمره في تبادل الرسائل ووثائق غير
رسميه مع واشنطن عبر وسطاء في المنطقه
وحتى عبر الاوروبيين عبد اللهيان قال ان
المفاوضات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي لا تزال
متواصله بشان الملف النووي الايراني وانه
على التواصل مع مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بشان الملف
النووي
لا يبدو ان العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
بقدر سهوله الخروج الامريكي منه بدات
مفاوضات احياء الاتفاق النووي في الثاني
من ابريل 2021 في فيينا واتسمت بكونها
مباحثات غير مباشره بين طهران واشنطن
استرفض ايران الجلوس على طاوله واحده
لمفاوضات مباشره مع الامريكيين ثماني
جولات من المفاوضات اجرتها ايران مع الغرب
تباينت ما بين مد وجزر من تحقيق اختراق او
عدمه لتعلق في اغسطس الماضي بسبب خلافات
جوهريه بين طهران و واشنطن من ابرزها رفع
العقوبات عن الحرس الثوري الايراني اذ
ترفض الولايات المتحده رفع الحرس الثوري
من قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه في اطار هذه
المفاوضات تطالب طهران برفع جميع العقوبات
بما فيها تلك التي اعيد فرضها بعد خروج
ترامب من الاتفاق النووي وتريد طهران ايضا
ضمانات بان الولايات المتحده لن تنسحب من
الاتفاق هذا علاوه على قضيه عثور الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على اثار لمواد
دمويه في مواقع غير مصرح بها والتي مثلت
نقطه تباين اساسيه خلال المباحثات ورغم
تعليق محادثات فان الاتصالات بين ايران
والغرب لم تنقطع تمثل ذلك في حراك
دبلوماسي ما بين مسقط والدوحه وطهران خمس
سنوات مرت على انسحاب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب من الاتفاق ناوي الذي
لم يعمر اكثر من عامين ونصف والواضح ان
مرور الوقت انما يزيد محاولات انعاش
الاتفاق صعوبه فالظروف التي ادت الى ابرام
الاتفاق نووي قبل 8 سنوات تغيرت اليوم
بالكامل اما تقدم البرنامج النووي
الايراني فيحد من امكانيه العوده الى
الوراء وعلى وجه الخصوص ما يتعلق بحجم
احتياطيات اليورانيوم المخصب لدى طهران اذ
اصبحت ايران تنتج رسميا يورانيوم بنسبه
تخصيب بلغت في موقعين تانز وفوردو وهو
مستوى اعلى بكثير من عتبه ثلاثه وسته
اعشار في المئه التي حددها الاتفاق النووي
الوكاله الدوليه تؤكد انها عثرت في مفعل
فوردو على جزيئات من اليورانيوم مخصبه
بنحو اربعه وثمانين وهو سقف قريب جدا من
التخصيب اللازم لصناعه اسلحه نوويه تعتمد
ايران على اجهزه طرد مركزي من طراز اي ار
سته تفوق سرعتها وكفاءتها الجيل الاول اي
ار واحد الذي يسمح به الاتفاق النووي وفقا
للوكاله الدوليه فان مخزون اليورانيوم
المخصب لدى ايران تجاوز الحد المسموح به
بموجب الاتفاق ناوي باكثر من ثماني عشره
مره اذ بلغ احتياطي طهران من اليورانيوم
3809 كلغ وهو اعلى بكثير من 203 كلغ فقط
يسمح بها الاتفاق نووي امام مخزون ايران
من اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60% فتجاوز 55
كيلو جراما هذا التطور لافت ومثير للقلق
بالنسبه للغرب لعلمهم ان 25 كيلو جراما من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 90% كافيه لانتاج
قنبله ذريه
معنى الانميات الكويت عدنان طبطبائي مدير
مركز كاربو للدراسات والباحث المتخصص في
الشان الايراني اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد
اذا يعني التقرير تحدث عن قلق امريكي غربي
متجدد من نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم الايراني
هذه اصبحت يعني شيء معتاد نسمعه بين وقت
واخر ولكن في هذا الوقت ايضا هناك الحديث
عن رسائل ووثائق غير رسميه يتم تبادلها
بين الطهران وواشنطن هل يعني هذا ان هناك
حل حاله في الملف النووي هل هناك شيء قادم
مثلا يمكن ان نتوقع
من الصعوبه بمكان الاجابه عن هذا السؤال
لانكم كما قلتم نحن نستمع باستمرار الى ان
هناك احتمالات وهناك اتصالات لكن دعونا
ننظر الى ما قد تغير وما تغير في محيطي
والجيراني ايران هناك
محاولات لتخفيف
التصعيد ومن العواصم المحيطه بايران هناك
مقاومه اقل لاحياء الاتفاق وايضا حتى مع
ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
هناك بعض التقدم في تعاملات الوكاله مع
طهران كما سمعنا ايضا بعض التقارير عن
احتمالاتي تبادل سجناء هذه قد تكون بمثابه
محفزات للعمل نحو محاولات جاده لاحيائه
الاتفاق النووي
ولكن السؤال هو هل ما يريح ايران في اطار
محيطها الاقليمي بالضروره يريح الغرب
بمعنى هل فعلا يمكن ان يعتبر بالضروره
محفز للعوده للاتفاق النووي
وربما يكون العكس
البلدان في المحيط
والجيران ايران كانت دائما
قلق من علاقات ايران مع الفراعل من غير
الدول من المجموعات المسلحه ومن سياسات
ايران في المنطقه
والدول المحيطه كانت اقل قلقا بشان برنامج
ايران النووي لكنها قلقه من ان الاتفاق
النووي اعطى ايران حجما واهميه اكبر لكن
محاولات التقارب مع السعوديه مؤخرا قد قلل
من هذه من براعه القلق هذه لكن الغرب يبقى
قلقا من برنامج ايران النووي وربما في
الوقت المتحده او اوروبا قد يشعرون بعمل
شيء ما قبل العوده الى اتفاق النووي مثل
ماذا
اخمن بان النقطه الاهم ستكون
الاضاحه لايران بان هذه المره الرفع
العقوبات يكون
مضمونا اكثر لكن مقابل
انسحاب امريكا الاحادي مثلا بناء او تدعيم
اليات بانه لو حدث ذلك فان ايران قد تحصل
على تعويضات مقابل ذلك وعلى ايران ان تثبت
ان التقدم الذي حصل في برنامج النواوي
سيعاد الى الوراء
2015 يمكن
لمقاطعتك بسبب ضيق الوقت شكرا عدنان
طبطبائي مدير مركز تربو للدراسات والباحث
المختص في الشان الايراني شكرا جزيلا
تعزز اسرائيل وجودها
وتموضعها السياسي والامني في دول جوار
ايران واخر خطوه في هذا الاتجاه كانت
افتتاحها سفاره في تركمانستان على بعد 20
كم من الحدود مع ايران في المقابل لا تخفي
ايران تعزيز وجودها العسكري في محيط
اسرائيل وهو ما دفع قائد الاركان
الاسرائيلي الاتهام طهران باستخدام سوريا
منطقه حرب محتمله مع اسرائيل التقرير
التالي يعرض صراع تعزيز النفوذ على الحدود
بين ايران واسرائيل
من ترك منستان على بعد 20 كيلومترا من
جارتها ايران بعد ذلك بايام يطل وزير
الخارجيه الايراني على اسرائيل من جارتها
لبنان
هي اخر رسائل حرب تعزيز الوجود على الحدود
بين ايران واسرائيل في سياسه محاصره الاخر
بعد افتتاح تل ابيب سفاره لها في عشق اباد
المحاذيه لحدود ايرانيه تركمانيه تتجاوز
1400 كيلومتر سبق ذلك وجود اسرائيلي اثار
قلق ايران على حدودها الشماليه في
اذربيجان
وتموضع اخر حرك عتدها العسكري عند حدودها
الغربيه في كردستان العراق وقبل هذا وذاك
سرعت اسرائيل مد الجسور الدبلوماسيه في
مناطق جديده بمحيط ايران فطبعت علاقاتها
مع البحرين والامارات ورممتها مع تركيا
ومن قبلها ارمينيا
ترفق مع ازدياد وتيره استهداف برنامجاي
ايران النووي والعسكري بعمليات امنيه
وسبرانيه خلال السنوات الاخيره
عندما يوجد الاسرائيليون في تركمانستان
واذربيجان وارمينيا ومناطق نفوذ اخرى حول
ايران فان ذلك سيضاعف قدرتهم على جمع
المعلومات الحساسه ويمكنه من استهداف
مصالحنا القوميه بشكل اكبر سياسه موطئ
القدم الاسرائيليه في دول الطوق ايران
لايجاد حلف مضاد لها في المنطقه الخليجيه
والجنوب القوقاز وغرب اسيا حديثه اذا ما
قورنت بسياسه موطئ القدم الايرانيه في
جوار اسرائيل لخلق درع امني متقدم كما
تقول طهران وان كان الوجود الاسرائيلي
باشكال سياسيه او امنيه فان الوجود
الايرانيه عسكري بامتياز لكنه يقوم على
علاقات سياسيه والطيده مع العواصم
فالمجموعات المسلحه في سوريا
وحزب الله في لبنان لا تخفي ولائها لطهران
حسين كنعاني مقدم ضابط سابق في الحرس
الثوري ممن ساهموا في تعزيز قوه حزب الله
منذ نشاته يقول اليوم ان الوجود الايرانيه
في محيط اسرائيل ابلغ اثره
الكيان الصهيوني يتضرر اكثر من ايران في
هذه المعركه
فقواعدنا في سوريا والمقاومه في لبنان
وغزه قادره على قصف الكيان بالصواريخ
يحذر كثيرون من ان حرب التموضع على الحدود
قد تتحول الى ما توصف بام الحروب في
المنطقه فهي تترافق مع تهديدات اسرائيليه
بضرب منشاه نوويه ايرانيه
وتهديدات ايران بتدمير مدن اسرائيليه
تزحف عقارب الزمن حثا نحو ما تبدو مواجهه
وشيكه بين ايران واسرائيل تقول طهران انها
اعدت العده على اكثر من جبهه بينما تؤكد
تل ابيب انها ماضيه في سياسه القتل بالف
طعنه بانتظار ساعه الحسم عمر هواش الجزيره
طيران
اعلن حلف شمال الاطلسي ارساله قوه
العمليات الاحتياطيه لغرب البلقان الى
كوسوفو وذلك لمواجهه الاضطرابات الاخيره
في شمال الاقليم حيث اصيبت 30 من افراد
القوات الدوليه لحفظ السلام والتي يقودها
ستتعزز فحلف شمال الاطلسي قرر ارسال قوه
العمليات الاحتياطيه لغرب البلقان الى
كوسوفو
وثمت ايضا كتيبه احتياطيه جاهزه لتتحرك
الى هناك في ظرف اسبوع
هكذا يتفاعل النيتو اذا مع اضطرابات
الشمالي كوسوفو الاخيره
تلك التي اصيب فيها عشرات من افراد قوات
حفظ السلام الدوليه التي يقودها الحلف
ضم ندين بشده هذه الاعتداءات غير المبرره
ضد قوات حفظ السلام التابعه للنيتو في
شمال كوسوفو والتي ادت الى اصابه نحو 30
جنديا مثل هذه الهجمات غير مقبوله ويجب ان
تتوقف
يتصدر الاوروبيون الاصوات الداعيه للتهدئه
بين سلطات بريشنا والمحتجين من الاقليه
الصربيه
يريدها مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه والامنيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي تهدئه دون قيد او شرط
يقول جوزيف بوريل انه يتوقع من سلطات
كوسوفو ان تخرج قوات الشرطه من محيط
البلديات في الشمال كخطوه اولى
حتى يهدا الموقف تريد روسيا من جانبها من
الغرب شيئا اخر اي يتوقف عما تعتبره
استفزازا لصربيا وتاثيرا في سلوك سلطات
لا يتوانى هنا عن اتهام قوات حلف شمال
الاطلسي بوجه خاص بانها عامل تصعيد تدافع
القوه الدوليه عن مهمتها التي تتلخص في
الوقت الراهن كما تقول في منع مزيد من
التدهور في الموقف
محيط مبنى بلديه سبيتشان حيث تعزز القوه
مواقعها ما زال وموقعان اخران ملتقى
للمحتجين الصرب على تنصيب رؤساء بلديات
جدد من القوميه الالبانيه
هم بذلك يرفضون نتائج انتخابات قاطعوها
شهر الماضي في مناطق تمركزهم وشهدت نسبه
مشاركه متدنيه
تدعم طرحهم فهي تدفع نحو اقامه رابطه
بلديات صربيه في شمال كوسوفو بعد الاحداث
الاخيره وضع مجلس امنها الجيش في حاله
تاهب قصوى وامره بالتحرك نحو الحدود
اما رئيس الصربي فيطالب بالانسحاب العاجل
لمن سماهم رؤساء البلديات المزيفين وافراد
قوات الشرطه الخاصه من عاصمتكوسوفو
وكوسوفو التي لا تعترف بها صربيا دوله
مستقله فوضتها قبل شهور برعايه امريكيه
واوروبيه الهدف كان الاتفاق على مسار
لتطبيع العلاقات بين بريشنا
[موسيقى]
تشهد حرب المسيرات تصعيدا متناميا بين
موسكو منذ اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وقد
تعرضت روسيا اكثر من مره لهجمات بالمسيرات
استطاعت اعتراض بعضها وتسببت اخرى في
خسائر ماديه متفاوته استنادا للروايه
الرسميه واكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
اعترضت الثلاثاء ثمانيه مسيرات في جنوب
غربيه العاصمه موسكو ومن بين المناطق
المتضرره شارع لينسكي بروسيكت وهو شارع
ضخم يعود الى عهد
وقد تعرض جزء من غرب موسكو تحديدا للهجمات
وهو المنطقه التي يقيم فيها الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الى جانب اعضاء الحزب
الاخرين في النخبه الروسيه
في بدايه مايو الجاري
اسقطت مسيرتان فوق الكرملين مركز السلطه
في موسكو في هجوم نسب
وتحطمت ايضا مسيره في كولومبيا التي تبعد
110 كيلومترات فقط من وسط موسكو
سابقا تحدثت وكاله تاسع عن هجوم لطائره
مسيره على مصفاه اليكسي للنفط قرب ميناء
المطله على البحر الاسود وذلك في منطقه
كراس ندار جنوبي روسيا ما تسبب في اندلاع
حريق
تستخدم في حرب المسيرات بين الطرفين عده
انواع من المسيرات واستنادا
لخبراء عسكريين تملك روسيا واوكرانيا
ثلاثه انواع من المسيرات وهي الدواره وذات
الجناح الثابت والانتحاريه
تستخدم كيف مسيرات دواره من طراز اوتيل 11
وهي صينيه الصنع ذات محرك كهربائي ويبلغ
عرض جناحها سته عشر او سته عشره بوصه
وتستطيع الطيران لمده اربعين دقيقه
كذلك هناك مسيرات دواره من طراز جولدن
امريكيه الصنع والتي يبلغ طول جناحها 20
بوصه سرعتها تصل الى 50 ميلا في الساعه
ايضا موسكو تملك مسيرات اخرى ثابته الجناح
وهي يو جي 22
الاوكرانيه الصنع ايربون هذا النوع من
المسيرات ويبلغ طول جناحها اثنين وثلاثين
قدما وتستطيع طيران للسبع ساعات متواصله
وتصل سرعتها 100 ميل في الساعه
المصادر المختلفه تتحدث عن امتلاك روسيا
ايضا مسيرات دواره وذات جناح ثابت
وانتحاريه منها
الدواره روسيه الصنع والتي يبلغ طول
جناحها
15 قدما وتستطيع الطيران لمده 60 دقيقه
كامله كذلك لديها مسيرات من طراز الروسيه
الصنع وطول جناحها ثمانيه ثمانيه وعشرون
قدما وتستطيع الطيران لمده 20 ساعه كامله
بسرعه تصل الى
125 ميلا في الساعه
لا ننسى ايضا مسيرات شاهد 136 الانتحاريه
الايرانيه الصنع والتي تبلغ سرعتها
185 كم في الساعه وهي كبيره الحجم لكن
صنعها منخفض الكلفه
الان ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بكاسيات العميد يعني ونحن يعني نستعرض
ابرز المسيرات التي تمتلكها موسكو اليوم
نريد ان نتحدث اولا عن الاثار واهميتها في
هذه المعركه الدائره يعني يبدو ان الاثار
حتى الان بين متوسطه والطفيفه كما وصف
هجوم اليوم ولكن الضرر الحقيقي هل هو
معنوي سيكولوجي اكثر من اي شيء اخر هنا
ولكنه ايضا لن يحسم الحرب يعني هو
المعامله بالمثل ونقل ارض المعركه الى
الداخل الروسي كي يحس الشعب الروسي ان
الحربه ليست عمليه خاصه عسكريه كما يسميها
الرئيس بوتين
عندما استعرضنا نوع المسيرات هي في الغالب
من الصرع الخارج
التكنولوجيا الروسيه اين هي الان هي التي
يعني نتذكر جميعا القرن الماضي القمر
الاصطناعي سبوتنيك والضجه التي اثارها في
ذلك الحين ولكن اليوم تكنولوجيا يعني
موسكو لا تملك الكثير هي ليس لديها انتاج
لشرائح ذكيه هي تستورد هنا ما قيمه هذا
المعطى في اطار ما نتحدث عنه
تعتبر ليلى يعني الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
لروسيه قبل هذه الحرب كانت تحتم وجود
مسيرات من نوع معين اغلبها كان يستعمل
للاستطلاع وجمع المعلومات وتحسين الرمايات
مدفعيه او صاروخيه الى ما شابه هنا تتاخر
بالصناعه والتكنولوجيا روسيه عن غيرها
لانه نعرف ان هي تستورد الرقائق الذكيه او
تشب من الخارج اكثر مما تصنع في الداخل من
هنا تستورد اليوم حاليا من ايران الشاهد
وهي تستعملها بطريقه وكانها مدفعيه معينه
انتحاريه يعني هذا الشاهد تحمل ما يقارب
50 كيلو جرام من التي ان تي وكانها
قذيفتين لمدفع 155 تستعملها لانهاك الواقع
في كييف واستنزاف الدفاعات الجويه
وبالتالي زر الرعب وهذا امر سيكولوج ي
ايضا
اشكرك كالعميد الياس حنا شكرا على وجودك
معنا في الحصاد بهذا اذا نختم الحصاد هذه
الليله نشكركم جزيلا على المتابعه
[موسيقى]